[Música]
empezamos esta sección de revista de
prensa por supuesto con una noticia que
está llegando de chile de último minuto
y la aprobación en la cámara los
diputados de ese país de la acusación
contra el presidente sebastián piñera
para ello ya está conmigo en el estudio
lista para analizar todo lo que ocurre
en ese país en los medios de
comunicación en los periódicos rosa
pérez master rosa una mañana de martes
10 moyano buenos días raúl exacto
abrimos con esta noticia de última hora
que ha sucedido a las 8 del 8 de la
mañana hora de santiago es decir hace
dos horas si te parece vamos a ver diez
segundos de lo que ha pasado en la
cámara de diputado una vez vamos a verlo
resultado de la votación por la
afirmativa 78 votos 67
[Aplausos]
bueno ahí está entonces las
declaraciones digamos lo que ocurría
cuando aprobaron esta decisión rosa pero
ahora vamos a ver como titular la
tercera y también la pauta esto como
comentábamos esto acaba de suceder pero
los medios de comunicación chilenos ya
han actualizado a estos portales estaban
prevenidos seguramente evidentemente la
tercera titula tras más de 21 horas la
cámara de diputados aprueba la acusación
constitucional contra el presidente
sebastián piñera por otro lado la pauta
dice cámara declara admisible la
acusación constitucional contra piñera
recordemos que esta moción de censura o
este impeachment contra el presidente
chileno se desencadenó a raíz de su
implicación en los papeles de pandora
por este conflicto de intereses en la
venta de sus acciones del proyecto
minero domingo recordemos él piñera uno
de los tres jefes de estado
latinoamericanos que figuraba en este en
estas revelaciones junto a luís abinader
de república dominicana y a guillermo
olaso de ecuador y ahora mismo pues como
decíamos por 78 votos
67 en contra y 3 abstenciones
queda aprobada en la cámara de diputados
está acusación constitucional que en los
próximos días deberá debatirse en el
senado y ahí y ahí es en la cámara alta
donde se va a decidir finalmente si se
destituye al actual presidente de chile
o no y esto recordemos además sucede a
pocos días de las elecciones
presidenciales en el mismo país vamos a
ver cómo afecta todo este revuelo
político a los diferentes candidatos
hacia rossi como la obesidad también
patricia la luna
hablaba que en la cámara alta pues
parece que la oposición no tiene los
votos necesarios para que entonces se
apruebe una destitución contra
presidente piñera pues todo puede pasar
vamos a estar muy atentos podemos saber
porque lo que lo que comentan los
distintos medios es exactamente esto lo
que hacen falta 29 votos y que la
oposición cuenta de momento con 24 web
rosa ahora si cambiamos de tema vamos a
lo que avanzamos en el sumario el diario
punto es el primer borrador de glasgow
habla de urgencia pero no de recortar
las emisiones es muy débiles según un
artículo lo hizo mi tocayo además raúl
desde glasgow esa ciudad escocesa exacto
este artículo que habla del primer
borrador de acuerdos de esta cumbre dice
que este texto previo no preliminar
califica la década 2020-2030 como
crítica pero que sin embargo es poco
ambicioso que hay países como brasil
australia arabia saudí- que bloquean que
este texto pues exactamente sea más
ambicioso como comentábamos que no
figuran pues más limitaciones a las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
y que incluso la directora de greenpeace
internacional señala a este medio es muy
preocupante que sea tan débil no augura
nada bueno vamos a ver marina colorado
seguro que nos va a informando de todos
los detalles desde glass así ese rosa y
más adelante en directo con 26 también
vamos ahora con bbc news mundo la
escalada de tensión y de belarús por la
llegada masiva de migrantes a la
frontera de la unión europea esto por
polonia también como lo estábamos
avanzando en nuestro noticiero esta
revista de prensa está bien partida
temas
pero que están en la actualidad e
internacional ahora exacto raúl este es
un foco mediático internacional ahora
mismo porque sucede que miles de
personas están bloqueadas en la frontera
de polonia
quería encontrar ahí desde belarús y
procedentes de medio oriente y desde
otros países de asia al llegar a las
puertas de la unión europea se
encuentran con 12.000 efectivos del
ejército polaco y con un muro de alambre
que ha levantado polonia así como otros
países también recordemos de la unión
europea como españa con a marruecos o
como grecia con turquía y lo que sucede
es que la unión europea acusa a
lukashenko de atacar a la unión europea
permitiendo la entrada de personas
inmigrantes hacia el territorio
comunitario y de hecho la presidenta de
la comisión europea aus la von der leyen
ha pedido a los estados miembros que
amplíen el régimen de sanciones contra
belarús dice por poner en peligro la
vida de personas pero recordemos también
raúl que la unión europea bloqueando la
entrada de estas personas
territorio también está vulnerando el
derecho internacional a la solicitud de
asilo y de protección y más ahora que
llega el invierno y las bajísimas
temperaturas en europa y según señala
este artículo y ha habido distintas
muertes por hipotermia en los bosques
fronteriza y además rosas recordemos que
se espera que este invierno sea bastante
duro bastante fuerte ahora con al yazira
el régimen talibán reparte esperanza de
paz en afganistán rural la imagen las
imágenes son de un guakil rosa cosa
perdón excepto este este artículo nos
ofrece una visión un poco alternativa de
lo que solemos comentar sobre afganistán
y se centra más en las áreas rurales
donde según comentan distintas fuentes
llegaba lo peor de la guerra y también
muy escasa ayuda internacional y lo que
señalan los habitantes de estas regiones
es que si bien se mantiene la pobreza y
en cierto modo también la violencia bajo
el régimen talibán por lo menos han
cesado los ruidos de bombardeos lo que
eeuu llaman daños colaterales
en las víctimas civiles de ataques
aéreos y que en cierto modo pues que ha
cesado pues el conflicto armado entre
entre ambas partes pues rosa gracias a
por toda esa información ahora nos vamos
de inmediato a presentar a nuestro
primer invitado del día gracias luego
mañana con más titulares de la prensa
internacional
[Música]